on Friday three Palestinian terrorists
opened fire on the holiest site in
Judaism at the Temple Mount they were
shot dead by police but not before
murdering two Druze police officers one
of whom has a three week old child one
of the terrorists reportedly played dead
as an emergency medic
then tried to stab the medic before he
was shot naturally the media's headlines
were insanely vague here's the AP quote
two Israeli policemen killed in shooting
near Jerusalem shrine the BBC quote
Israelis injured in gun attack near
Jerusalem holy site al-jazeera breaking
at least three Palestinians killed in
shooting in Jerusalem's Old City Getty
Images Israeli policeman killed three
Palestinians in al-aqsa mosque all of
this is in keeping with the mainstream
media's dedication to imposing moral
equivalence where none exists holy sites
in Israel are routinely under assault
not from Jews but from Palestinians
Palestinians have burned Joseph's Tomb
multiple times they've spent years
destroying archaeological evidence of
Jewish presence on the Temple Mount
itself whenever Palestinians attacked
you is the official response from the
supposedly peaceful Palestinian
Authority is to continue funding
terrorism than offer a vague statement
about stopping violence on all sides
meanwhile the Israeli government has
already announced it will maintain
current policy on the Temple Mount which
favors Muslims to such an extent that
Jews are not even allowed to mouth'
silent prayers on the Temple Mount again
the holiest site in Judaism when cities
like Bethlehem the number of Christians
is dropped from 50% of the population to
12% and terrorism is still a serious
threat in 2002 Palestinian terrorists
actually use the Church of the Nativity
as a safe haven all of this is
demonstrative of the fact that Israeli
control of holy sites is the only way to
preserve their free and open access yet
the United Nations continues to rip away
Jewish yesterday piece by piece claiming
that the Temple Mount and the Cave of
the patriarchs in hebron are not Jewish
but Palestinians historical sites don't
expect the truth to emerge anytime soon
the media are dedicated to perpetuating
this conflict they see Israel as a
colonialist aggressor in a historically
Arab region and committing themselves to
broadly obliterating Judaism's
millennia-long pre-existence of islam no
it's all just a cycle of violence as
always i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
all right many a thing to get to we have
a very busy show today so we will give
you the latest on all of the Trump rush
of stuff then we're going to be talking
with Mark Levin in just about 15 minutes
here he will be stopping by and that'll
be awesome and then after that we are
going to do the mailbag so lots to get
to on today's show but before we get to
any of that I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Skillshare
so if you are a professional in the
working world today you cannot expect
you are going to just be able to have
the same skill set now and in 30 years
and have the same job that's not how the
job market works anymore since I left
law school I've had like five or six
different jobs that's fairly typical
people move jobs now you have to
constantly be increasing and expanding
the set of skills that you have and
that's where Skillshare comes in it's an
online learning community with over
15,000 classes in design and business
and more everything from logo designs to
social media marketing to street
photography all of these are in
45-minute classes basically unlimited
access to all of it you get for a low
monthly price you never have to pay per
class again reference here's some of the
classes the day that they talk about
right design Adobe Illustrator and logo
design and typography and animation
entrepreneurship they branding and web
design public speaking I have taken a
watercolor class from Skillshare yes I I
have I will one day paint like George W
Bush Skillshare gives all of my
listeners the ability to learn all of
these new skills you can put them on
your resume you can broaden your
capacity to get a great job with
Skillshare Skillshare comm slash repair
you get your free month you get a month
of unlimited access to all of these
classes skills shared comm slash Shapiro
it's receiving every month and you're
going to want to renew because the fact
is that it's just a fantastic fantastic
service Skillshare comm slash Shapiro
absolutely free that month but limited
access and you redeem that free month
again use the slash cap heroes that they
know that we sent you
okay so last night after all of the
Trump Russia Don jr. stuff seems to have
boiled down a little bit and everybody
seems to have retreated to their
respective corners in this fight a new
article from The Associated Press breaks
and here is what this article says quote
a Russian American lobbyist says he
attended a June 2016 meeting with
President Donald from son marking
another shift in the accounts of a
discussion that was billed as part of
the Russian government effort
to help the Republicans White House
campaign Rinat Akhmetov participations
The Associated Press on Friday mention
has been reported to have ties to
Russian intelligence agencies though he
denies ever working as an intelligence
agent which is what you do if you're an
intelligence agent he told the AP he
served in the Soviet military in a unit
that was part of counterintelligence but
was never formally trained as a spy so
we just keep learning that more and more
people were at this meeting so
originally the meeting never happened
then the meeting happened but it was
just with this crazy lady who wanted to
talk about adoption then it turned out
that the crazy lady who wanted to talk
about adoption was billed as a Russian
government lawyer who's going to spill
information about Hillary Clinton in
order to help Russia's pro-trump
campaign and now it turns out there is a
second Russian there with apparent
intelligence ties so just awesome guys
from administration if you want us to
believe you on these things you are
going to need to stop omitting details
that are not details right you're going
to actually have to come clean about
this and then we'll all let it go
because as I have said a million times
there's no evidence of law violation
there's no evidence that actual active
collusion took place even beyond us I've
been saying this for a while but I'm
still confused by the Democrats theory
of what collusion would constitute do
they think that the Russians went with
WikiLeaks and hack the DNC and then they
were giving hints to Trump about what
would come I didn't see that at all
during the campaign did you I didn't see
any speeches where Trump was like
there's something unbelievable it's
going to drop tomorrow at Ted Pepa get
ready and then the next day WikiLeaks
dropped something I didn't see any of
that and I didn't even see that the
Trump campaign was on top of the content
of the WikiLeaks like then they'd been
pretty warned and all of a sudden an
hour later they militarized it and they
exploited it what I saw was WikiLeaks
was releasing a lot of stuff and then
people like me were group sourcing it
crowdsourcing it so that we could see
what exactly was in there so a lot of
this is again I still don't see what
exactly they're saying the strategy was
here that said Trump is going to have to
do a better job of telling the truth on
this and so it's Trump jr. if they want
this whole thing to go away so yesterday
President Trump is in France and it's
been a week since he's answered any
questions from the press and he answers
one question from the press on the Trump
jr. Russia scandal and here was his
rather long ish answer as far as my son
is concerned my son is a wonderful young
man
he took a meeting with a Russian lawyer
not a government lawyer but a Russian
lawyer
it was a short meeting it was a meeting
that went very very quickly very fast to
other people in the room they I guess
one of them left almost immediately and
the other one was not really focused in
the meeting I do think this I think from
a practical standpoint most people would
have taken that meeting it's called
opposition research or even research
into your opponent okay and he continues
along these lines you said you know it's
called after the research I've had many
people I've only been in politics for
two years I've had many people call up
and say oh gee we have information on
this doctor or this person or frankly
Hillary that's very standard in politics
politics isn't the nicest business in
the world but it's very standard where
they have information and you take the
information and the case is done he
listened I guess they talked about as I
see it they talked about adoption and
some things and then he goes on and he
says that it's really Obama's fault
because attorney general Lynch brought
in this natalia vessel mantilla
character this is Russian lawyer in
January as I said yesterday I think
that's a bunch of crap I think the idea
that that that she was brought in as
some sort of attempt to get the Trump
team is just silly there's a little bit
of an inherent contradiction there
yesterday Trump did a white house it
wasn't really a press conference but he
did kind of a White House press pool on
Air Force One yesterday and then he
ended up revealing some of it and
apparently he said to the press pool
well he may have known about the meeting
at some point but I didn't know they
wouldn't talk about Hillary well that is
a difference from what your own people
said like two days ago where they said
you had no idea that the meeting was
happening so again if the story keeps
changing
I want to believe the Trump
administration because I don't actually
think anything the ferry has happened
here okay I'm not coming from a place
where I want to see all of this blow up
on from I'm not interested in that I
think it would endanger any sort of
Republican agenda that we have left if
Trump were to completely fold and
collapse and this whole thing were to
end up being a giant scam but he's going
to have to do better than this just from
any objective point of view he needs to
tell the truth and come clean I was on
Steven Crowder show yesterday we were
agreeing that one of the things you do
in politics is when there's something
that's quasi scandalous you get out in
front of it by explaining it before
anyone else has a chance to so Barack
Obama did it wonderfully and dreams for
my father there was also
parts of Apple material in there that
really could have damaged him
particularly the idea that when he was
in college in high school he did a
little walk remember he said this in a
zip I did a little what that a little
drugs wasn't big deal and everybody saw
well you know what an honest guy as
opposed to in 2000 George W Bush didn't
revealed that he'd had a DWI when that
came out then that actually ended up
hurting his his or DUI that ended up
hurting his his credibility right before
the election it ended up probably losing
him the popular vote that DWI DUI so the
fact is he you know the you have a
chance here if you're the Trump team to
get out in front of this thing and
explain what exactly you were doing
they're not doing that very well so far
meanwhile you have the the people of the
Trump administration trying to say to
the media you need to pay attention to
real issues well it's hard for people
needed to pay attention to real issues
when again you keep not telling the
truth of Sebastian Gorka I think
actually usually does a very good job in
the media he's owned Jake Tapper and he
says listen why don't we paying
attention to the fact that people are
dying in Syria while are dying in Syria
that's why Jake why do you have your
number do you not care about the
devastation a half a minute I do well
we've got life in Russia is killing some
of those feel life and we've got life
and death issues and if we can create a
ceasefire which we did with Israel with
Jordan involved that what we have to do
we have to move on
okay so Gorka is trying to say let's get
back to the issues again the best way to
get back to the issues is to actually
bring focus back to the issues as
opposed to having all these silly
scandals running around as Charles
Krauthammer says this really is Keystone
Cops kind of stuff well I'm not
impressed by the story about the lawyer
I think it's it's a red herring the size
of a whale she was a pawn it doesn't
change the central fact in the scandal
scandal is that the email received from
an intermediary by Donald Trump jr. said
that a Russian government lawyer
because Reagan was wrong he's not a
little
women lawyer we'd be coming with dirt on
Hillary and that the Kremlin was
supporting his campaign and that the
Crown prosecutor that's a misnomer the
state prosecutor in the Kremlin had a
trove of documents that they would offer
that's the story I don't think it's
illegal I don't think anybody claiming
that this illegal but it does the one
thing it does that would totally
undermines a six-month story from the
White House to which I was sympathetic
that there wasn't any collusion this was
a bungled collusion okay when you've
lost about her mother's crowd hemant has
been very skeptical of the Trump Russia
stuff for months at this point and the
White House needs to do a better job of
explaining itself now meanwhile one of
the great ironies in all of this is that
Democrats are now super super pissed at
Russia
so yesterday Brian Fallon who's a
Hillary spokesperson he comes out and he
says Mitt Romney was right we never
should have knocked him over to the
Russia stuff yeah well thank you I
appreciate it five years too late thanks
for all of that you jerk but this is
what's happened is that politics has
become so gross that everyone has now
switched positions you've got Paul
Begala out there as Rush Limbaugh a
skull on the forehead out there saying
we should blow up Russia that we should
bomb Russia over this we were and are
under attack by a hostile foreign power
and they seem to be abetting that
hostile foreign power we should be
debating how many sanctions we should
place on Russia or whether we should
blow up the KGB r GSU GRU I mean we
should be retaliating massively because
by the way if I were Trump supporter I
would want to retaliate massively
because I hated it has taken his victory
okay and and so now all of a sudden we
should blow up Russia right so these are
the same people who said was no big deal
in 2012 and Barack Obama wanted to offer
flexibility to the Kremlin now he says
we have to blow up Russia right Nancy
Pelosi saying Russia has desecrated our
democracy they desecrated our democracy
gum their dentures on moving around all
weird and such in the month again as we
celebrate the courage of our founders
Republicans in Congress have become
enablers of the Trump Russia assault
okay we stop it right there okay and
then on the right so now so now all the
sudden the Democrats are really anti
Russia and on the right you have people
like Tucker Carlson whose show I enjoy I
think Tucker's a really talented guy but
Tucker yesterday a couple nights ago he
did a debate with max food that I
thought was really not intellectually
honest in some ways from from Tucker in
which Tucker actually says the Russia is
not a top-five threat to the United
States or her interests and then he
actually ended up defending Iran he
ended up saying well when did one's left
on Iran killed Americans after 9/11 max
we'd said well they killed hundreds of
Americans in Iraq you know so the what
we have here is Iowa Hawk whose Alerus
Iowa Hawk on Twitter he says basically
we're no longer playing in a game with
rules we're playing Calvinball
like from Calvin and Hobbes where the
rules just shift randomly and suddenly
switch sides and it turns out the hated
Russian five minutes ago but now you
love Russia or you loved Russia five
minutes ago but now you hated Russia now
the Republican defense to all of this
has been the one that I think Richard
Grinnell points out Richard Grinnell as
a former I believe who's a former
adviser to the UN Ambassador and he says
look everybody outside of Washington DC
doesn't care about this Russia stuff
this is I think the bottom line defense
being used by a lot of Trump defenders
today I'm not sure it washes I think I'm
the only one that doesn't live in
Washington DC here and people don't care
about this there's such a difference
between listening and acting I think
Donald Trump jr. listened to something
that was brought to him okay we can stop
in there because here's here's I think
the point people on the right wanna do
this routine where we say well if you
look at from space he's not being
abandoned by his base he will never be
abandoned by his base that's why they're
called whose base has like 30% of the
population that's great okay it's great
that Trump has a base of 30% of the
population that's good for any
Republican president fantastic okay the
fact is when you say that the common man
doesn't pay attention to the Russia
stuff that's like saying the common
person doesn't pay attention to the
Hillary Clinton email stuff Democrats
said that for an entire election cycle
and it turns out that two things can
happen to cause you to lose elections
one is you lose your base but the second
is that your base decides they're not
that enthused and they're going to stay
home okay that's what happened to
Hillary Clinton in 2016 it wasn't that
her base didn't exist it existed it was
larger than Trump's it was that people
decided they didn't care enough about
her that they were going to go out there
and fight for her sapping the energy
from your base is a problem and right
now all of this energy and focus being
spent on Russia does Sapta base
it would be one thing if Trump were
pushing some sort of world-shaking
policy and then his people would have
something to be enthusiastic about but
right now there's no world shaking
policy the only thing that seems to jazz
up the bass in the absence of policy is
Trump tweeting out stuff about makeup
Brzezinski's face which maybe that's the
strategy maybe the idea is that if Trump
tweets things out about people we don't
like then we get all excited about it
but I'm not sure that's enough to win
over the people who voted for Obama
twice and then voted for Trump or to get
a lot of people out to vote in 2018 you
have to motivate your voters somehow and
one way you motivate your voters is by
saying here's all the things I've done
and the other way to motivate your
voters is by saying I'm a better person
than the people who oppose me and when
you're in when you're in a situation
where every day is a new scandal that
you can't clearly explain what exactly
you're doing it causes problems for you
and again I don't even think this is not
coming from a place if I think Trump is
guilty of anything I don't think there's
any evidence of that what I'm saying is
come out explain what your position is
and you'll save everybody a lot of grief
I mean I listen I would prefer to spend
the day talking about the stupidities of
Amanda Marcotte and her and her idiotic
feminism okay but I can't do that
because of all this stuff okay I mean I
can but I'll have to spend less time on
it than I normally would okay before we
go any further before we have on Mark
Levin in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. ECA so you know it's important
that you're able to defend yourself
important that you're able to defend
your family but what happens after you
pull the trigger well that's where the
UFC CA comes in not only do they educate
you and train you and they make sure
that you are legally and financially
protected for after you pull the trigger
because even if you shoot someone under
justified circumstances you're going to
end up in the legal system that cost
lots and lots of money and lots and lots
of time you SCCA make sure that you are
covered right now that are even offering
an awesome deal if you go over to defend
my family now calm then you actually get
a free shot at winning 1776 dollars
worth of guns and ammo 1776 worth of
guns and ammo you have five big chances
to win by registering and defend my
family now calm you should go to defend
my family now calm anyway because that's
going to give you all of these added
benefits it's going to allow you to get
that education and that training and
that coverage for its god forbid you
actually have to pull the trigger on
somebody so make sure you go to defend
my family now.com you get those five big
chances to win 1776 tellers sword any
done the guns and ammo of your choice is
just amazing defend my family now
dot-com go over and check it out okay
so we had the opportunity to speak with
Mark Levin the great one we spoke with
him I guess this would have been
yesterday and and so now I want to play
the interview as a brand new book out
and Mark is just terrific
I'm a huge fan so here we go we are so
pleased and honored to welcome to the
ben shapiro show one of my ideological
mentors and a guy who i think brought a
lot of people into the conservative
movement a mark levin nationally
syndicated talk show host host of levin
TV chairman of the landmark legal
foundation and of course author of a
thousand bestselling books including
liberty and tyranny his new book is
rediscovering Americanism and the
tyranny of progressivism I have read it
it is like all of his other books a
treatise on conservatism that everybody
needs to read mark thanks so much for
joining the show Ben it's a great honor
and let me just say this I get no more
joy than when I watch you on TV
kicking some liberal around I really do
enjoy I appreciate it well I mean I have
to say that I still recommend many of
your older books men in black is still
the the go-to book for for me to
recommend when it comes to judicial
activism so I want to talk about your
new book because it really does
something that I think we need to do as
conservatives tibs right now which is
re-educate our own side and other people
about what our fundamental principles
are because we've gotten so caught up in
the partisan bashing which is fun and
and necessary but we've got so caught up
and sometimes we forget our own central
principles what is what exactly are we
fighting for other than mean tweets
about the other side and so in
rediscovering Americanism you talk about
what the founders would have thought
about today's America and you basically
say that they would have thought that
the government is unrecognizable why do
you think that well I do believe that
and so what I do is I go back to the
beginning the Declaration of
Independence and I look at the
principles their laws of nature when's
the last time we talk about the laws of
nature I was never taught about the laws
of nature I took advanced philosophy and
political science and history and all
the rest of it if this is the core of
our founding so where do these
principles and ideas come from in the
Declaration the founders didn't invent
them what they did invent though is a
country that was based on them that had
never been done before in America in the
world history and hasn't been done since
so when I started thinking about what I
was going to write I do
started writing and I didn't have
chapters I wrote the entire book and
then I went back and broken into
chapters as best I could
it's really two forces and that is this
force of the Enlightenment of
individualism of freedom of an
inalienable rights what Aristotle talked
about these universal law and truths
these eternal truths where did the
founders get this rim well they tell us
Aristotle Cicero Locke Sydney and a
whole bunch of others and so I went back
I've read them before I went back and
read them again and I tried to pull
information from them to inform people
who are interested in what the founders
were reading and why is that important
because when you start to read this
material even though you and I we love
our country you really even love it more
because you realize wow these ideas are
absolutely incredible and they predate
this country and they go back thousands
and thousands of years and so I felt if
more and more people fully understood
what we mean rather than the surface
leveling or I believe in Liberty and I
believe what that means and more and
more people can spread the word
conversely there's a dark side in a
bleak side in a miserable side and
that's what we call progressivism I
don't like the word I wrote a whole
booklet Ameri topia condemning the word
but to be historically accurate that's
their nomenclature so I I talk about
progressivism in the Progressive Era and
where does that idea come from and who
are their philosophers and you have to
look at people like Rousseau and Hegel
and Marx among others and you realize
how completely contrary that is to our
founding principles and then you look at
the so-called intellectuals who advance
those principles in what I call this
counter-revolution to the American
Revolution people like Woodrow Wilson
and Crowley and while and Dewey and so
forth and so on and I explained who they
are I explained what their ideas are and
I quote them and I quote them a lot so
people don't think of making this stuff
up and they and they attack the
declaration and they attack these
principles even the word Liberty the
word Liberty folks need to understand
that there's some controversy around
this word Liberty you and I we mean you
know the circle of Liberty
surrounds each individual human being
god-given Liberty god-given unalienable
rights like it says in the Declaration
again they talked about laws of nature
and nature's God what does that mean
does that mean you have to be religious
no what it means is though that there
are things bigger than man their ideas
truths bigger than man eternal universal
truths so if you're born in Washington
DC or you're born in Paris France you
know right from wrong you know the
Golden Rule you know you're not supposed
to kill people or rob people it's not
because their laws made by man it's
because these are things we know and re
reason through them and that's what the
framers believed when they wrote the
Constitution to the progressives however
by name it's why quota attack these
principles they attacked the Declaration
they say the Declaration was a
revolutionary document for a
revolutionary period pioneers throwbacks
but today is today we can't worry about
all these mystical ideas these eternal
truths we got to look at the world as it
is today we have to into it and and
rationalize and figure out what the
truths are and create this this society
where the experts are trained and
professional district trained to try and
address the problems we have today which
leads us to this massive administrative
state that's not in the Constitution
that passes four thousand laws a year
without our consent they don't care what
we think about them they go on whether
we have elections or not and this is
what I try and get across in the book
and also I interlink the principles
because they are which is individualism
freedom private property rights and
constitutional republicanism you need
every one of those elements to be a
fulsome human being in order to pursue
your your interests and so forth when
one is under attack they're all under
attack and today they're all under
attack well my mark one of the things
that is fascinating in your book and you
talk about this with regard to the
Progressive Era the book again is
rediscovering Americanism one of the
things that's fascinating
is that the progressives when they first
came around they're actually very open
about the fact that they were attacking
the founding that they thought the
Declaration of Independence was passed
say Woodrow Wilson did a whole speech in
which he talked about how the
Constitution
United States needed to be put aside and
shelved because it was just hampering
our ability to get things done
today's left seems to have understood
that it is a mistake to attack those
terms and so there are a lot more
insidious you see Barack Obama I thought
his second inaugural address is perfect
proof of this where he started actually
quoting the founders to justify
precisely the opposite of what the
founders would have wanted that's why I
think it's so important that you
distinguish what they would have wanted
but did the founders language I mean I
love the founders as much as you do did
the founders language we be opening for
the left to take it and run with it in
other words when they say things like we
hold these truths to be self-evident and
the left says well it's not self-evident
to me but here is a self-evident truth a
self-evident truth is that poor people
can't take out of themselves until we
need a welfare state or it's universal
law of nature there will be poor people
in other words the natural law I know
this is a big kind of abstruse debate
between West Coast regions and East
Coaster alkanes but is there a it did
the the doctrine of natural law that the
founders all believed universally did
that open the door to the possibility of
a progressive twisting of that of that
terminology to say well you know they
put in place this constitution which was
the governing manifestation of these
principles in the Declaration so they
thought they could do they did the very
best they could to put these checks and
balances in place with direct election
of the house these state legislators
legislators electing the Senate an
electoral college process for the
president United States judges who would
be immune from elections and so forth
and they explained what they did but to
answer that question there's a letter in
the book from Thomas Jefferson to John
Adams and these are two old men at this
point and Jefferson is just ruminating
about Rome a little bit about Athens and
Rome and he says you know obviously I'm
paraphrasing he says you know John I've
been thinking about Rome and he said
they had Cicero great man they had Cato
great man
they had Brutus great great man these
are men who were smaller Republicans and
who put their lives on the line
challenging the emperor in the system
that was in place into the corruption
and so forth
and he said if all those men together
were able to fashion a government a
Republican government it would have
failed and he said in the reasons I've
been thinking about this because the
people lacked virtue there was nothing
that could be done to save that society
even if Caesar had been gone and those
three men ruled and and put in place the
Republican form of government it
wouldn't have worked it was too late so
to answer your question I don't point to
the founders in the language of natural
law as the reason why we are where we
are we are where we are excuse me
because of this invidious ideology that
has taken place and they have their
Linsky tactics and their marxist tactics
and all these other tactics and so forth
and so on but as a people either we
believe in Liberty regardless of what
the media say in the in the demagogue
say either we in our hearts and our soul
and our minds want to be a free people
or we don't and I would suggest to you
that about a third of us want to be a
free people about a third of us don't
and about a third of us don't give a
damn and so that's about where we are
today I think which I mean the good news
is that was exactly the breakdown during
the American Revolution and the right
guys ended up winning the bad news is
that we could certainly lose so with
that in mind the mark I you're missing I
didn't ask you if you had to give it
some advice to President Trump right now
on what he could be do to further the
cause of the causes you're talking about
I'm not sure the president from thinks a
lot about ideas like natural law or
constitutionalism but he still he could
be an effective tool for these things if
he would do some of the right things so
what do you think you know president
Trump ought to do at this point to
promulgate the sort of values you talked
about in rediscovering Americanism and
on the same page you know is there
anyone in Congress that can be trusted
to for these values at all because
obviously Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
are doing a pretty shoddy job of it thus
far you know Paul Ryan called me many
months ago when he was pushing his
nonsense with this Obamacare and I had
told his people I don't want to talk to
me why waste his time so but he insisted
so I spoke to him first thing he says to
me is I read all your books and I said
but do you digest them because obviously
you read all the books do you digest
them and I said and why you're wasting
your time calling me and for 45 minutes
we had this chat last time but I the
problem right now with the
administration is it's under a full-bore
attack and they're trying to dislodge
this president I don't agree with this
president on everything as you well know
and I backed Ted Cruz in the Republican
primary there are things I do agree with
this president on and including a
selection of judges his attack on the
regulatory estate and certain other
things but what I cannot accept is the
effort by the left to continue to try
and destroy this Republican the election
results and that's what I see going on
with a lot of this Russia stuff mistakes
are no mistakes the left was going to
find something and we'll continue to
look for something in order to overturn
this election the way they attack the
electoral college the way they attack
all elements of our constitutional
system if I were advising the president
I would say take a closer look at the
judiciary because 40 percent of these
judges were appointed by Barack Obama
we have many vacancies and Schumer is
slow-walking them and he's slowing him
down I would pull Mitch McConnell in my
office and I would say all right damn it
get rid of that filibuster rule if
that's what we have to do that's what we
have to do we're up against this
entrenched radical leftist mob and if
they're prepared to burn the place down
I'm not prepared to burn the place down
but the filibuster rule is the
filibuster rule and you're going to have
to suspend it if we're going to get
anywhere I mean the Senate quite frankly
is this absurd entity now since the 17th
amendment where we have two people
elected directly from the people of each
state why do we need to send you know
it's a side point I start to ramble as a
side point I love it when the left says
let's get rid of the electoral college
we don't need any well let's get rid of
the Senate I mean the Senate was
supposed to represent the state
legislatures why do we have two senators
from every state if they don't represent
the state legislatures but I think he
should focus on on that I also think if
they don't drop that filibuster rule
he's not going to get much done and
Mitch McConnell's not going to get much
done you know I've been saying we ought
to read
bill and replace McConnell because he is
going to kill the Republican majority in
that Senate so there's no easy answer to
that question as to who we can rely on I
can tell you Mike Lee is a very earnest
and studious constitutional conservative
I think Ted Cruz is the same I think
Rand Paul in most instances I don't
always agree with them is similar and
there's a handful of others the problem
is the overwhelming majority are not and
the reason is the Republican Party I
think is largely a progressive party
they have never eliminated any
departments or any agencies they
remember it seriously curbed their power
cut their budgets they don't attack the
debt when they're in office look at this
Obamacare debate this is a perfect
example that I would relate to the book
it's not in the book that we relate to
the principles in the book the entire
debate is on the progressive field you
know we got to say Medicaid well who's
killing Medicaid they mean to expand
week on from repeal Obamacare to expand
Medicaid but most of us aren't on
Medicaid that's a welfare program what
about the rest of us and so Ted Cruz
offers this incredibly radical amendment
which says okay look offer your damn
Obama care policy insurance companies
but let them offer whatever they want to
the rest of us oh my god you can't do
that
why well it might hurt Frank and Sally
and and then Damian and this one in that
one in other words a complete
abandonment of liberty of market
capitalism and competition that has
created this magnificent Society
Industrial Revolution you know this is
the only place where 3:00 in the morning
you can walk down the street to a
7-eleven and buy darn near anything you
want or at 10:00 in the morning go into
a grocery store you've got stuff from
all over the country all over the world
almost everyone can afford it we live
like kings and queens could never live
200 years ago we can get on a jet and
fly from one part of the country to
another part really for a fairly
inexpensive amount an air-conditioned
luxury at six hundred miles an hour
forty thousand feet off the ground and
if you want they'll serve you
peanuts while you're doing it I mean
think about what the principles of the
founding created right and think about
what they're doing to it and they attack
it all the time so I got to tell you
then my perspective on this is
Washington is lost we vote we do the
very best we can
this is the design they have created
which is a perversion of what the
founders intended we have got to
convince each other as citizens the way
the colonists did of the of the
greatness of this country of the
disaster of the other side and if we
can't win minds and hearts then we can't
win
the book is rediscovering Americanism
and the tyranny of progressivism another
number one New York Times bestseller
from Mark Levin who is the author of
just a bevy of them at this point mark
thanks so much for everything that you
do and thanks so much for joining me
sure I always appreciate it it's a great
honor I love when you fill in for us my
audience loves it too and God bless
thanks so much
okay so there is there it is a great one
Mark Levin now before we go any further
and I do want to talk about things I
like and I have some pretty epic things
I hate as always today plus the mailbag
so lots more to get to I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors over a
policy genius so if you do not have life
insurance you are making a big big
mistake everyone should have life
insurance because it is just protection
for the future yes I'm sorry to bring
you the sad news we will all die at some
point but if you die unexpectedly and
you leave your family nothing then
that's just you being an idiot so please
go over to policy genius pol I see why
genius GE and I us.com
and they will give you the best online
life insurance marketplace the most
accurate quotes from the top a rated
life insurance companies they place over
five billion dollars in life insurance
for people like you they have a simple
user-friendly website to shop and
compare all your top-rated life
insurance policies and give you the best
options again that's policy genius calm
you'll save over 40% off other prices
for life insurance I mean they're that
competitive policy genius.com they also
have to be able to salesman trying to
upsell you or anything pol I see why
genius.com policy genius.com go ahead
and check it out they are a great
company and honestly I think I had a
little bit people okay so as I say
before we go any further I now have to
let you go on Facebook you've got an
extra long
Facebook today an extra-long YouTube
today for those who don't actually watch
our show okay you should know it's an
audio show you can listen to it but it
is also a video show can watch the
entire thing live if you are a
subscriber over at daily wire.com like
you don't cut out if you would be on
Facebook or YouTube like you watch the
whole thing live continuously over at
daily we're calm for just $9.99 a month
we also get to be part of the mailbag
which will be doing momentarily making
your life a better better thing you also
get to be part of Andrew Clayton's mail
bags and get his show live
Michael Knowles will be having a show
God love us and that will be live as
well as to get all sorts of goodies we
have brand-new goodies coming as well
plus if you get the annual subscription
then $99 annual subscription you get
this this very mug if not I'm not
allowed by contract that's steven
crowder to call it a month this
unbelievable tumbler do you see the
magnificence of this tumbler there has
never been a tumbler quite like this one
it says upon it left is tears hot or
cold in silver letters that will send a
shudder down all leftist spines it's
great for collecting with tears it's
great for drinking the tears make sure
that if you are going to actually drink
tears that they have been sterilized in
some way because I don't know why I
would want to get to these because of
but the cup itself is fantastic left
this year's hot or cold it also works
for coffee and other beverages that
you're more likely to drink on a daily
basis unlike me I drink them every day
leftist here is hot or cold you get that
month for 99 dollars over at daily
wire.com or batana listen later go over
to iTunes or SoundCloud and give us a
listen subscribe but leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay since it's such a busy day I'm
gonna go straight to things I like and
things I hate at this point okay so time
for a thing I like so this entire week
thanks to Donald Jr we have been doing
movies and books about sons who are
disappointed fathers who are
disappointed in their sons and today we
have a classic of the genre I'm speaking
of course is Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade this movie is really underrated
because Raiders is so good so people
tend to underestimate how good les
Crusaders Temple of Doom is an awful
film like so legitimately bad film and I
mean Kate Capshaw man whoo but it but
Indiana Jones in Last Crusade is a truly
wonderful film it's fun it moves quickly
I know that the daily wires on Jeremy
boring prefers it to Raiders I don't
think that's allowed I think that you're
not allowed to prefer it to Raiders the
reason being that the entire predicate
for Last Crusade is the presence of
Indiana Jones before it stands alone as
a film but you have to know who Indiana
Jones is in order for it to work because
the whole premise is that Indiana Jones
Mathis and I were discussing earlier the
whole premise is that Indiana Jones is
the coolest person on the planet and his
father thinks that he's a giant loser
nerd that's the entire premise of the
film it's really fun Sean Connery they
search for the Holy Grail and I won't
give away spoilers like the spelling of
particular versions of God's name in any
case here it is Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade logo the preview we're
about to complete a great quest the Holy
Grail after Jones
wrath the shield is the second marker
Indiana Jones is on the quest of light
time but for some adventures one jose is
not enough jr. don't call me that
please hurry
I'll race across three continents and in
this sort of race there's no silver
medal for finishing second
into the homeland of the enemy I hate
these guys
it's pretty raishin there's nothing it's
awesome sean connery it's really really
fun it's also good to do this because I
believe yesterday was Harrison Ford 75th
birthday looking pretty good for 75
Harrison I mean I hope I look as good as
Harrison Ford any points in his life
I hope I look as good now as Harrison
Ford look at 75 stuff
well done Harrison Ford's a great movie
a lot of fun Indiana Jones and Last
Crusade and of course it is hilarious
that Sean Connery thinks that Indiana
Jones is this giant disappointment okay
time for some things that I hate so the
first thing that I hate today is this
insane piece by some crazy person named
Jodi Allard she's apparently a feminist
blazer first of all all feminist
vloggers are I don't mean to generalize
but they're all crazy so she actually
has a piece today called
the title of it I'm done pretending men
are safe even my sons really and the
entire thing is about how her sons are
potential rapists she says I have two
sons they're strong and compassionate
the kind of boys other parents are glad
to meet when their daughters bring them
home for dinner they're good boys and
the ways good boys are but they are not
safe boys I'm starting to believe
there's no such thing she is talking
about her own children being potential
rapists because of rape culture that
wrote an essay in the Washington Post
last year during the height of the Brock
Turner case about my son's and rape
culture I didn't think it would be
controversial when I wrote it I was sure
most parents grappled with raising sons
in the midst of rape culture well no
actually it turns out that the vast
majority of us who grow up his boys in
households that have their parents were
not part of a rape culture because we
are taught at a very early age that
you're not supposed to rape people right
that rape is a bad thing I thought this
is pretty clear rule Western
civilization for the past thousand years
or so cause I didn't think it would be
controversial when I wrote it the
struggle I wrote about was universal I
thought but I was wrong my essay went
semi viral and for the first time my
sons encountered my words about them on
their friends phones their teachers
computers and even overheard them and
discuss my strangers on a crowded metro
bus right because when you say your
son's are potential rapist that might
have some bad ramifications they're your
kids you stupid idiot and then she says
it was one thing to agree to be written
about in relative obscurity and quite
another to have my words intrude on
their daily life by the way this is the
same lady who wrote a column about how
one of her sons was apparently suicidal
with a mother like this and she
says one of my sons is suicidal so we
sat down and watched 13 reasons why are
you the stupidest person on planet earth
okay have you ever seen 13 reasons why
like half the show is dedicated to why
suicide is a choice that is driven by
outside forces it's not really in your
hand anyways she says one of my sons was
hurt by my words with both he's never
told me so he doesn't understand why I
want him and his brothers together in my
essay he sees himself as the good one
the one who is sensitive and thoughtful
and who listens instead of react he
doesn't understand that even quiet
misogyny is misogyny and not all sexist
sound like Twitter trolls so he seems
like a nice kid but she's calling him a
sexist and rapist he's angry at me now
although he won't admit that either and
his anger led him to conservative
websites and YouTube channels okay if
the son of Jody Allard is watching this
right now please write me an email I
would be happy to have you intern with
us here over at the Daily wire I think
that you deserve better than what your
mother has provided to you a label as a
potential rapist I don't think you're a
rapist I don't think you're a potential
rapist you seem like a nice person
your mother however seems like she is a
harridan she does I theater frequently
between supporting my son and educating
him and if my job is his mother to
ensure he feels safe emotionally no
matter what violence he spews can she
give an example but the violence that
our son is feeling is he coming home
going very pretty very break like what
what exactly is he doing and he coming
home and he's just saying I saw a girl
on the bus today you know what I thought
about rape I'm pretty sure that's not
what happened but when you're a crazy
person then this is what happened then
she starts talking about her dating life
okay why didn't some minutes always feel
the need to talk about their dating life
like anybody cares so they join bumble
recently after a six plus year break
from dating I'm not overly interested in
dating in the first place but I'm
starved for adult conversation so dating
feels like a necessary evil well no
there's some of us who have friends and
you could do that and she's bumble as I
explained to my married friends it's
like feminist tinder women have to
initiate contact with men so there's no
inbox full of bleep pics every day but
feminists are not the men are no
different from the men anywhere else and
I felt I quickly felt deflated all men
are you okay I have a general
recommendation if you believe that all
men or all women are crazy that
everybody's terrible maybe it's just you
maybe it's just you if every
relationship you've ever had is going
bad maybe it's not because all the
people you know are terrible maybe you
suck as a human okay and I'm going to go
with that on this one just my son
or rape unconscious woman behind a
dumpster and neither one most of the
progressive men I know but when all of
these men share in common even my son's
is a relentless questioning and
disbelief of the female experience and
realized the common female experiences
to be raped while unconscious behind a
dumpster I know a few females and I
don't know any of them have been raped
while unconscious behind a dumpster at
least none have told me about it and if
they didn't tell me about that I would
say can we find the person and hump them
down let that be my first reaction can
we tell the police and if not is there a
way that we can kill this person to get
away with it like that seems like the
best positive like is that not feminist
enough there's actually more than I do
not want to prove my pain or provide
enough evidence to convince anyone that
my trauma is merited if you accuse
someone of rape you might have to
provide evidence of actual rape you
shouldn't just be able to accuse anyone
of any crime totally insane totally
insane Child Protective Services needs
to show up like right now at this lady's
door thank God it sounds like her sons
are getting old enough they get to leave
home leave now
leave now okay I will try to find a way
to put you up in your own apartment
seriously okay you deserve to get out of
there right now Jodie Allard's children
my god okay other thing that I hate so
uh Conor McGregor is the Irish correct
he's the Irish MMA star who is going to
fight Floyd Mayweather I mean by fight
Floyd Mayweather is get knocked out in
all likelihood by Floyd Mayweather
because it's not it's not his sport I
mean he's not a boxer right he's an MMA
fighter I've been saying for a couple of
weeks that I think the best outcome here
is the Conor McGregor six rounds like
eight rounds and then the very end when
it's clear he's going to lose you just
as a roundhouse kick and whether it
violates all that was the greatest thing
in boxing history roundhouse kick to
Floyd Mayweather in any case apparently
everybody was very angry because Floyd
Mayweather and in Conor McGregor were
like verbally sparring with each other
which is what people do at these events
that's the whole reason they have these
events they flew in on the same jet okay
folks it's a show and Conor McGregor
said this boy is that all week
stinger Timmy I want you to sing it
Jimmy and I want you to go honey
you kids you can schedule me boys
okay so this is basically WWE kam and
Fox Sports when Rob Parker
he says note that says this just shows
that Conor McGregor is racist can we
call it an international incident
I got admin and I know that's Connors mo
and how he operates and all that but it
just doesn't feel good to me I have a
hard time listening to it I'm not even
talking about the curse words just the
tone of it and I'm gonna say this
skip it comes off as racist to me okay
more may come on - come on does
everything have to be racist or can it
just be a couple of buffoons who are
yelling at each other I mean like really
really does everything have to be racist
yeah you're right it's white
supremacists Conor McGregor going after
Floyd Mayweather in about they're going
to hold it's kind of a quasi joke
already for a hundred million dollars
like really really again my
recommendation is this despite ends with
with Conor McGregor actually using MMA
rules in violation of the rules and I
think it'd just be hilarious if you
roundhouse kicks Floyd Mayweather
Mayweather goes down is knocked out and
then as he's unconscious on the floor
the repetition declared him the victor
the greatest specter in boxing history
okay time for some mail bags or whatever
so Jennifer says hey but I'm a big fan
of your work I wanted to get your
opinion and insight on the topic of
homeschooling I plan on being a
stay-at-home mom and the teacher to my
children anyway so homeschooling -
doable option do you think it's the best
choice when it comes to different
schooling options to pick from options
such as homeschool private school in
public school well I do not like most
public schools there are some good
public schools I generally prefer
private school to home-school the only
reason being I think it is important for
kids to spend time away from the house
but homeschooling is a wonderful option
my sister was home-schooled for at least
a year I have friends who have been
Alicia Krause is a friend of mine she's
a homeschool kid a wonderful gal so a
homeschooling seems to work very well
and it's a better option you have to
assess this for your own kid some kids
don't need the interactive time with
other kids if you are going to
home-school obviously you have to take
an extra measure to make sure that your
kids socialize with other kids but I
don't think the chief purpose of school
is socialization and so many people
think is acting it's education Casey
says I was recently arguing rights don't
require the labor of others when someone
brought up juries don't
require the labor of people to be on a
jury to fulfill the right to a jury so
yes
the right to a jury is is basically a
imposed right it's not a natural right I
don't think that it's like if you I
think there are plenty of justice
systems that the founders would have
embraced I don't think they believe that
there is a quote/unquote natural
god-given right to a jury they believe
there's a right to due process of law in
other words when you have a state that
is established for the purpose of
protecting right there has to be some
sort of process of law by which they can
convict you you know the same question
can be asked about Courts
court-appointed attorneys the idea of
these kind of Rights this is a sort of
positive right the right to have a jury
because you are imposing on others but
as I say that is only because the state
is now invading your normal rights and
so we have to protect those rights with
some sort of system so it's not the same
and say a right to somebody else's labor
for for welfare or for your poverty or
to make excuses for your decision-making
hey Bella says as conservative
Millennials grew up in entrant hood how
can we prepare our children for a
society to teach his kids they can't
pick their nose but they can pick their
gender or punch anyone who disagrees
with them well I mean I think that's a
pretty good rested position I think that
if you teach your kids how ridiculous
that is that's a good way to do it but
we have to laugh at this we have to mock
this because it is insane and we tend on
the right to do this routine when we
don't want to offend people because we
have the right tend to be more polite
than our counterparts on the left and so
we don't want to offend we don't want to
be the jerks but I'm sorry it is absurd
that you are suggesting that people can
pick their gender but they can't pick
their nose Vashti which is it that's a
cool name I haven't heard that in really
only time I've seen that is is in the
the book of Esther as a conservative
college student we might be trading my
principles by accepting federal loans
and government aid for my college
education I don't think that you're
violating your principles mean you're
going to pay those loans back I think
that the federal government is violating
its principle for being by offering the
loans I'm not sure that you're violating
it by taking the loans when you are
repaying your loans meaning that you are
doing what you are supposed to do now if
you vote in favor of the loans that's a
different thing if you vote because of
the loans that's a different thing but
no I mean I took federal loans it would
make me a hypocrite to say that other
people can't take federal loans I think
the entire concept of federal loans
shouldn't exist but that's sort of like
saying I don't think that I should
to pay $800 to the stated city that I
don't think that in order to start a
business in the state of California I
should have to pay an $800 licensing fee
but I do it because I start a business
okay well when they remove the law then
I'll do that and I'll fight to remove
the law I'll fight to remove the federal
student loans Gio says hey Ben do you
believe the secret to success in
happiness is doing what you love for a
living thank you I think that there is a
difference between doing what you love
for a living and doing what you are
capable of doing for a living so I do
think that one of the secrets to
happiness is doing something that you
love but I think that you should try and
define what you love by something you're
good at laying in other words if what
you love to do for a living is play
basketball and you're really bad at
basketball I don't think that's a recipe
for happiness I think that you should be
and you should be in order to determine
do something that you love and are good
at you love many things find something
you love and are good at because then
you will be happy if you pick something
you love and are bad at you will be
upset because you'll feel the world is
screwing you ACL writes dear Ben why is
climate change essential left the issue
I've heard you explain the primary
principle undergirding les policies is
equality of outcome not equal
opportunity does this principle
undergird the policies the left pursues
on climate change and if yes how so okay
so ASA the answer is yes it is the
remedies for climate change that are
problem for the right so there are a lot
of people on the right including that
there's a guy named Omri I'm forgetting
his last name now Omar Khayyam recast
anyway it's a very good piece about what
climate change is if it exists my own
opinion on climate change by the way the
climate change does exist that global
warming is happening we don't know to
what extent it's happening but even if
we accept the general IPCC which is
flawed but we accept the general
Intergovernmental Panel commission on
climate change even if we even if we
accept their estimates that does not
mandate that we should all basically
shut down our cars and it certainly
doesn't mandate a great wealth
redistribution my feeling is the best
answer for climate change is the same
answer that we've given to virtually all
other environmental issues which is you
regulate where there are emissions that
cannot be prevented on the other way but
mostly the market solves this kind of
stuff I mean the fact is that your car
has gotten more efficient it hasn't
gotten more efficient because of cave
standards it's gotten more efficient
because it's cheaper for people to drive
more efficient cars and because those
cars are better now people are buying
tests
right now because they're cool so I
think the market forces can be used in
order to push toward a more
environmentally friendly world I don't
think that the same things for nuclear
power I don't think that you need
governmental regulation the left seems
to start from the premise that they want
governmental regulation and then they
reason their way backward Dylan says
German what is your stance on people who
burn election posters from parties they
disagree with not sure if this occurs in
the US but here in Northern Ireland
around 12th of July that our bonfires
burned with nationalist party election
posters featured prominently on the
scrap to be burned
should this be considered a crime I
don't think it should be considered a
crime to burn any sort of message I
don't think it should be a crime to burn
the flag I think flag burning is evil
but I don't think that it should be a
crime to burn it I think lots of things
are evil but I'm not enough of a
governmental advocate to suggest that we
should make everything I don't like
illegal
lucas's hello Ben is it wrong for
private businesses to hide the salaries
of other workers in the company
capitalism involves voluntary exchanges
between employer and employee yeah I
notice how when I try to get a raise the
employer typically asks what do you
think you're worth while you have little
to no background about the average
performer receives in the company do
companies or individuals have the means
to mitigate this so that employee can
get paid what they are worth well you
decide what you're worth right I mean
this is the market assumes better flow
of information but if there's worse flow
of information you still have the
capacity to bargain right so yes would
your life be better would your life be
easier if you could determine what the
other people in your company are being
paid sure your life will be better and
easier but it's not the obligation of
the company to give you that information
this is why you should talk to your
friends and get a general idea and why
people should refuse to sign contracts
that say this I mean as a worker you can
say listen if there's a confidentiality
provision about my pay I don't want to
sign that I think most companies are
probably not thinking that's a huge deal
the fact is that you can get a pretty
good metric of what you ought to be paid
by just doing a little simple research
online I think as a general rule Ryan
says what would Trump have to do during
the next three years to get your vote
for him in 2020 well he'd need to
actually promulgate some policy so my
standard for Trump has always been that
I need him to actually promulgate
conservative policy and I need him not
to wreck the conservative brand those
are my two big things I think that he
has done some heavy work and hurting the
conservative brand he's pushed judge
Gorsuch was a good policy but
yeah I think that it let's put this way
it's a shorter putt for him to win my
vote in 2020 than it was for him to win
my vote in 2016 the reason being that in
2016 I still thought that the damage
that a lot of the damage that we've done
by the Republican Party by him being
president would be short-term damaged
and long-term damage he's already the
president now so a lot of that damage
has already been done it's already in
the past right a lot of the things that
he's done to the conservative brand have
already been done so now we are working
from a reality where the conservative
brand is what the conservative brand is
what that means is that is he going to
damage things much further or he's going
to make things better and that's the
question when it comes to 2020 okay so
we will be back here next Monday we have
a surprise for you from daily wire this
should be coming on Sunday so keep an
eye out for it it is going to be fully
awesome and ridiculous and crazy as
everyone at the office
can attest it is an insane thing that we
are going to put out on Sunday I think
you will enjoy it so check that out I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
you